This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. In 1863, a terrible plague descended on the famed vineyards of France. Tiny sap-sucking insects attacked the roots and leaves of grapevines. The pests destroyed thousands of acres. What turned the problem into a calamity was that French vineyards were mainly planted with a monoculture, a single species of grape that had little natural resistance to the insect hordes. It turns out that there are other kinds of species, for example, in the US, that were not so affected, that developed natural resistance to that pest, but that was not the case of the French vineyard. This is researcher Jordy Quodbach. He said the
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。1863年，法国著名的葡萄园遭遇了一场可怕的瘟疫。微小的吸汁昆虫攻击了葡萄树的根部和叶子。这些害虫摧毁了数千英亩的土地。使这个问题演变成灾难的原因是，法国的葡萄园主要种植单一作物，即对这群害虫几乎没有天然抵抗力的单一葡萄品种。事实证明，其他种类的品种，例如美国的品种，受到的影响并没有那么大，它们对这种害虫产生了天然抵抗力，但法国的葡萄园并非如此。这是研究员乔迪·夸德巴赫。他说，
destruction continued for years and threatened the very existence of the French wine industry. Eventually though, French winemakers found a solution. Adding diversity to the grape vines under cultivation. They started grafting their native vines onto American plants, which had evolved to resist the insects. By increasing the biological variety of the plants, the French wine industry rose again. To me, the takeaway of this story is that by introducing more diversity, you're actually making your environment more resilient and more likely to succeed in the long run. Today, we extend this idea from ecology to the world of psychology.
毁灭持续了多年，并威胁到了法国葡萄酒产业的生存。不过，最终法国的酿酒师们找到了一个解决方案。为人工种植的葡萄树增加多样性。他们开始将本地葡萄树嫁接美洲植物上，这些美洲植物已经进化出抵抗害虫的能力。通过增加植物的生物多样性，法国葡萄酒产业再度崛起。对我来说，这个故事的启示是，通过引入更多的多样性，你实际上是在让你的环境更具弹性，从长远来看更有可能成功。今天，我们将这一理念从生态学延伸到心理学领域。
Specifically, we examine the effects of having a variety of emotions in our daily lives. This episode is part of our Emotions 2.0 series. We've previously explored the power of collective emotions, the complicated psychology of pride, and the benefits of mixed emotions. If you missed any of those episodes, please listen to them in this podcast feed. This week on Hidden Brain, many of us go to great lengths to be happy, reading books, devouring podcasts, even joining cults that promise to set us on the path to joy and fulfillment. But is our singular focus on positive emotions actually good for us?
具体来说，我们审视日常生活中拥有各种情绪的影响。本期节目是我们的“情绪2.0”系列的一部分。我们之前探讨过集体情绪的力量、复杂的自豪心理以及混合情绪的好处。如果你错过了其中的任何一期节目，请在该播客推送中收听。本周的《隐藏的大脑》中，我们许多人为了追求快乐付出了巨大的努力，阅读书籍、狂刷播客，甚至加入承诺带我们走上快乐与成就之路的邪教。但是，我们对积极情绪的单一关注真的对我们有益吗？
Or does it set us up for calamity? Look on the bright side, accentuate the positive. See the glass as half full, not half empty. From billboard signs to t-shirts with inspirational messages, our culture has many ways of telling us to banish negative emotions from our lives. At one level, this makes perfect sense. Being sad and upset are unpleasant feelings. As humans, we are wired to seek the pleasant and avoid the unpleasant. At the Asadi Business and Law School in Barcelona, Spain, psychologist Jordi Quadbach has spent many years studying what happens when we try to live in an emotional monoculture. Jordi Quadbach, welcome to Hidden Brain.
还是说这为灾难埋下了伏笔？看到光明的一面，强调积极的一面。把杯子看作半满，而不是半空。从巨型广告牌到印有励志信息的T恤，我们的文化有各种各样的方式告诉我们要把负面情绪从生活中驱逐出去。从某种程度上说，这完全合乎情理。悲伤和心烦是不愉快的感受。作为人类，我们天生就会寻求快乐，逃避不快。在西班牙巴塞罗那的阿萨迪商学院和法学院，心理学家乔迪·夸德巴赫花了多年时间研究当我们试图生活在情绪单一文化中时会发生什么。乔迪·夸德巴赫，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。
Thank you, Shankar. It's a pleasure to be here. A number of years ago, Jordi, you were hit with some powerful emotions around the time that you and your wife were starting a family. I understand that you had long wanted to be a dad? Yeah, my partner, she got pregnant and we were both excited about it. And sadly,
谢谢你，香卡。很高兴来到这里。乔迪，多年前，就在你和妻子开始组建家庭的时候，你遭遇了一些强烈的情绪冲击。据我了解，你一直很想当爸爸？是的，我的伴侣怀孕了，我们俩都对此感到兴奋。但不幸的是，
you know, around three months, she had a miscarriage. So we were both devastated by the news. But at the same time, it turns out that on the following day, we had been invited to visit close friends of ours that just had a baby. And so had been invited to visit close friends of ours that just had a baby and so we were invited to meet the baby and have dinner with them. I'm wondering if you can describe for me what that evening was like when you went over. You're carrying this very heavy news in your own hearts but you're also there to celebrate a very happy moment in the lives of your friends. What was that like that evening?
你知道，在大约三个月的时候，她流产了。所以这个消息让我们两个人都崩溃了。但与此同时，事实证明，就在第二天，我们应邀去拜访了一对刚生了孩子的密友。所以我们应邀去拜访了一对刚生了孩子的密友，所以我们被邀请去见那个婴儿并和他们共进晚餐。我想知道你是否能为我描述一下，当你过去的时候，那个晚上是怎样的。你们的心里承载着非常沉重的消息，但你们同时也是为了庆祝朋友生活中的一个非常快乐的时刻。那天晚上是什么感觉？
It was very difficult because I mean we had just lost maybe not a baby but at least you know the prospect of a baby and we're there to celebrate their newborn and so we didn't want to ruin their fun and their and their joy and so we just tried very hard to change our emotions and to be excited for them. I'm wondering, did you bring up at all with your friends what had happened to you and your partner? So we didn't bring it up. We felt that bringing this sad story on a happy day for them would just... We just thought that it would ruin the mood. I think we did a really good job at suppressing these emotions to try to be excited for our friends. And that took a toll. And I'm assuming you were actually genuinely happy for your friends.
这非常困难，因为我的意思是，我们刚刚失去了，也许不是一个孩子，但至少你知道一个孩子的希望，我们去那里是为了庆祝他们的初生婴儿，所以我们不想破坏他们的快乐以及他们的欢乐，所以我们只是非常努力地改变我们的情绪，为他们感到兴奋。我想知道，你有没有和你的朋友提起过你和你的伴侣发生了什么事？所以我们没有提起它。我们觉得在这个对他们来说快乐的日子里带来这个悲伤的故事会……我们只是认为这会破坏气氛。我认为我们在压抑这些情绪以试图为我们的朋友感到兴奋方面做得很好。这付出了代价。而且我假设你实际上真的为你的朋友感到高兴？
I mean, that was also true. I mean, you must've been very happy that your friends had this newborn in their lives. Yeah, we were very excited. And then the newborn was absolutely cute and delightful. It's hard not to feel warm, fuzzy feelings when you have a newborn in your home. So it was so paradoxical what we were experiencing.
我的意思是，这也是真的。我的意思是，你的朋友生活中有了这个新生儿，你一定很高兴。是的，我们非常兴奋。而且那个新生儿绝对是又可爱又讨人喜欢。当你的家里有一个新生儿时，很难不感到温暖、美好的感觉。所以我们所经历的是如此矛盾。
Jordy noticed that as he and his partner suppressed their feelings, it changed the way they behaved. I think it prevented us from being fully present that evening. You know, every time a negative thought would pop into my head, I would need to sort of step out of the present moment and exert some mental effort to bottle it down. So there was definitely like a short-term sort of negative effect of suppressing or sadness, sorrow.
乔迪注意到，当他和伴侣压抑自己的感受时，这改变了他们的行为方式。我认为这阻碍了我们在那天晚上完全投入其中。你知道，每当一个消极的想法跳进我的脑海里，我都需要某种程度上跳出当下，付出一些心理努力把它压抑下去。所以压抑我们的悲伤、哀愁，肯定有一种短期的负面影响。
But I think there was also longer-term consequences of that because it turns out that on the following day, again, we could not fully experience our sadness because we had this trip planned to Japan with a group of friends and everybody was super excited to go to Japan and we didn't want to ruin the fun again for everyone. So we did not share that experience. And we went on a two-week vacation, and we didn't talk about what happened for two weeks.
但我认为这也有更长期的后果，因为事实证明，在第二天，同样地，我们无法充分体验我们的悲伤，因为我们计划了一次和一群朋友去日本的旅行，每个人都超级兴奋地去日本，我们不想再次破坏大家的乐趣。所以我们没有分享那段经历。我们进行了一次为期两周的假期，并且两周都没有谈论发生了什么。
So you didn't tell the friends that you were on vacation with what had happened? So we didn't tell them what had happened, but it also didn't almost talk about the event between ourselves, me and my partner. It's like we're just trying to ignore our feelings so that we could enjoy our vacation. And I recall that during the trip, the mood between me and my partner was not that great. So we were able to sort of to showcase to our friends, you know, excitement and for the Japanese adventures. But we had a lot of like tiny little conflicts and you know, passive-aggressive interaction during the trip.
所以你没有告诉你一起度假的朋友发生了什么？所以我们没有告诉他们发生了什么，但我们几乎也没有在我和我伴侣之间谈论这件事。就像我们只是试图忽视我们的感受，以便我们能够享受假期。我记得在旅途中，我和伴侣之间的情绪并不是很好。所以我们能够向我们的朋友展示，你知道，对日本冒险的兴奋。但我们在旅途中有很多像微小的小冲突，你知道的，被动攻击的互动。
And in the following month, we didn't talk about having another another shot at having a baby. We didn't talk about having another shot at having a baby. It's almost like because we did not allow ourselves to experience the emotions, and in a way that was now maybe too late to have these emotions, it was a month later, we couldn't fully process the event. And I think it took me and her probably three, four months before we started talking about it. So more recently, Jordi, a friend of yours came to you with some painful feelings
在接下来的一个月里，我们没有谈论再次尝试要一个孩子。我们没有谈论再次尝试要一个孩子。这几乎就像是因为我们不允许自己体验这些情绪，并且以某种方式现在可能为时已晚而无法拥有这些情绪，那是一个月后，我们无法完全处理这件事。我想我和她大概花了三四个月才开始谈论它。所以最近，乔迪，你的一个朋友带着一些痛苦的感受来找你
of his own. Can you tell me what he was distressed about? Yes, a good friend of mine who had moved out of love for his girlfriend to Spain and had a recent kid, a newborn, got dumped out of the blue. And he didn't really know why his partner left him. He was suspecting that she had met someone else. That was sort of the only thing that made sense for him. And so he was very suspicious, very jealous and he talked about this, you know, suspicion
他自己的感受。你能告诉我是什么让他感到苦恼吗？是的，我的一个好朋友，为了爱情搬到了西班牙和他的女朋友在一起，最近有了一个孩子，一个新生儿，却莫名其妙地被甩了。他真的不知道为什么他的伴侣离开了他。他怀疑她遇到了别人。这可以说是唯一对他说得通的事情。所以他非常多疑，非常嫉妒，并且他滔滔不绝地谈论这种，你知道的，怀疑
and sort of jealousy in great length. And my reaction was sadly the typical sort of bro reaction, trying to say like, look, you know, it's probably not a big deal, she'll probably be back, don't worry about it, don't stress about it, there's no reason to be jealous and so forth. And I even sort of caught myself pulling my phone
和那种嫉妒。而我的反应不幸地是典型的兄弟式反应，试图说：“听着，你知道，这可能没什么大不了的，她可能会回来的，别担心，别给自己压力，没有理由嫉妒等等。”我甚至发现自己掏出手机
and showing my friend this brand new dating app that my students were talking about, right, trying to say, hey, plenty of fish in the sea, and that he sort of hit me. I was not at all listening to his emotions and I was trying to provide solutions that he didn't ask me for. And I'm wondering, Jordi, if you can just articulate what you were trying to do for your friend when you were trying to turn him out of this blue mood and turn him to more cheerful thoughts. What were you trying to do? I was naturally trying to make him feel better.
向我的朋友展示我学生们一直在谈论的这个全新的约会软件，对吧，试图说，嘿，天涯何处无芳草，然后他有点爆发了。我根本没有听他的情绪，我只是在试图提供他并没有要求的解决方案。乔迪，我想知道你是否能表达清楚，当你试图让他从这种沮丧的情绪中走出来，转向更快乐的想法时，你当时在试图为你的朋友做些什么？你当时在试图做什么？我自然而然地是想让他感觉好一点。
I thought that if he could just ignore his jealousy, rationalize his jealousy away and look at the bright side, you know, all the potential mates out there for him, that would make him feel better and solve the situation. I'm wondering, did it have the same effect on him that you thought it was going to have? It didn't. I think he might have gotten frustrated and, you know, he came back repeating the same suspicion, the same jealousy and so forth. So I don't think we were like really connecting to each other.
我以为如果他能忽略自己的嫉妒，用理性驱散嫉妒，看看光明的一面，你知道，外面所有潜在的对象，这会让他感觉更好并解决现状。我想知道，它对他的影响是否如你所想的那样？并没有。我想他可能已经变得沮丧了，你知道，他回来时重复着同样的怀疑、同样的嫉妒等等。所以我认为我们并没有真正地相互连接。
So this makes me think about the 2004 movie Eternal Sunshine of the Spotless Mind. That movie also wrestles with similar themes. In the movie a character named Joel who's played by Jim Carrey is consumed by painful emotions after breaking up with his girlfriend Clementine, who is played by Kate Winslet. That's when he hears a doctor describe a potential treatment for his grief. Why remember a destructive love affair? Here at Lacuna, we have perfected a safe, effective technique for the focused erasure of troubling memories. In a matter of hours, a patented non-surgical procedure will rid you of painful memories
所以这让我想起了2004年的电影《美丽心灵的永恒阳光》。那部电影也探讨了类似的主题。在电影中，由金·凯瑞饰演的乔尔在与凯特·温丝莱特饰演的女友克莱门蒂娜分手后，被痛苦的情绪所吞噬。就在那时，他听到一位医生描述了一种针对他悲伤的潜在治疗方法。为什么要记住一段毁灭性的爱情？在拉克苏纳，我们完善了一种安全、有效的技术，用于有针对性地消除烦人的记忆。只需几个小时，一项获得专利的非手术程序就会帮您摆脱痛苦的记忆
and allow you a new and lasting peace of mind you'd never imagined possible. So Joel goes through with the procedure, and I think a lot of people watching the movie might imagine that they too would choose to erase painful memories if they had the choice. Why do you think this fictional scenario is so compelling to us, Jordi? Yeah, I love the premise of the movie because it really
并让您获得从未想象过的新而持久的内心的平静。所以乔尔经历了这一程序，我想很多看这部电影的人可能会想象，如果他们有选择的话，他们也会选择抹去痛苦的记忆。乔迪，你认为为什么这个虚构的场景对我们如此具有吸引力？是的，我很喜欢这部电影的前提，因为它确实
resonates with the natural tendency we have, which is to avoid emotional pain, right? And this is a very extreme version of it, but I think in everyday life, we do this kind of procedure But I think in everyday life, we do this kind of procedure all the time. We drink sometimes too much because we don't want to feel anxiety or sadness. We avoid asking for a raise even though we should probably ask for it because we don't want to experience fear. And so there's many, many ways in which we avoid experiencing unpleasant emotions and at the end of the day I think this avoidance creates even more problems. You raise a really interesting point just now Jordi which is that we all in some ways have our
与我们拥有的自然倾向产生共鸣，那就是逃避情感痛苦，对吧？这是一个非常极端的版本，但我认为在日常生活中，我们一直在进行这种程序，但我认为在日常生活中，我们一直在进行这种程序。有时我们喝得太多，因为我们不想感到焦虑或悲伤。我们避免要求加薪，尽管我们可能应该要求加薪，因为我们不想体验恐惧。因此，有很多很多方法让我们逃避体验令人不快的情绪，而到头来，我认为这种逃避会产生更多的问题。你刚才提出了一个非常有趣的观点，乔迪，那就是我们所有人都在某种程度上拥有自己的
own internal surgical techniques to remove these unpleasant emotions. We're not using scalpel and lasers, but we have these mechanisms to push these unpleasant feelings away. We do. And I think, you know, most of the time that's a healthy way to deal with unpleasant feelings, right? So if I'm stressed before an interview with you, Shankar, I might watch a fun movie to sort to distract myself from these unpleasant feelings and it's probably adaptive. I think the problem is when we chronically start avoiding unpleasant feelings.
内部外科技术来移除这些令人不快的情绪。我们没有使用手术刀和激光，但我们有这些机制来把这些令人不快的感受推开。我们确实有。而且我认为，你知道，大多数时候这是一种应对令人不快感受的健康方式，对吧？因此，如果我在与你面试前感到压力，香卡，我可能会看一部有趣的电影来把自己的注意力从这些令人不快的感受中转移开，这可能是适应性的。我认为问题在于当我们开始长期逃避令人不快的感受时。
As I said, you know to see that the avoidance, experiential avoidance as therapists call it, starts to create even bigger problems than the emotion itself. Jordy and his partner thought the best thing to do with their sadness was to push it away. When a friend brought painful feelings to Jordy and his partner thought the best thing to do with their sadness was to push it away. When a friend brought painful feelings to Jordy, he thought the way to help was to highlight the positive.
正如我所说，你知道，看到这种逃避，正如治疗师所称的体验性逃避，开始产生比情绪本身更大的问题。乔迪和他的伴侣认为处理悲伤的最佳方法是把它推开。当一个朋友给乔迪带来痛苦的感受时，乔迪和他的伴侣认为处理悲伤的最佳方法是把它推开。当一个朋友给乔迪带来痛苦的感受时，他认为提供帮助的方法是强调积极的一面。
The characters in Eternal Sunshine of the Spotless Mind went so far as to completely erase negative emotions from their memories. When we come back, the value of what psychologists call emotional diversity. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Given the choice, most of us would rather feel good than feel bad. But could there be a reason to invite in all kinds of emotions into our lives? At Asade Business and Law School in Barcelona, Spain, psychologist Jordi Quadback studies what happens when we stop trying to keep unhappiness from entering our lives. Jordi, farmers and ecologists have long known about the value of biodiversity in nature.
《美丽心灵的永恒阳光》中的角色甚至从他们的记忆中完全抹去了消极情绪。当我们回来时，心理学家称之为情绪多样性的价值。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。如果有选择的话，我们大多数人宁愿感觉良好也不愿感觉不好。但是，有没有理由将各种情绪引入我们的生活呢？在西班牙巴塞罗那的阿萨迪商学院和法学院，心理学家乔迪·夸德巴赫研究了当我们停止试图阻止不快乐进入我们的生活时会发生什么。乔迪，农学家和生态学家长期以来一直了解自然界中生物多样性的价值。
I understand that you have borrowed this concept from biology and applied it to the study of human emotion. Tell me about the idea of emotional diversity. emotion. Tell me about the idea of emotional diversity. So emotional diversity or emo diversity as we call it, is the richness and relative abundance of the emotions that we experience every day. And this really comes from research in biology and ecology showing that more diverse environments, both in terms of how many different kinds of species there is, but also how evenly distributed these species are in the environment, tend to be more resilient. So I started looking at the way we could capture this diversity and this idea of richness and balance of emotion. And it turns out that there are thousands of papers in ecology that do that.
据我了解，你从生物学中借用了这个概念，并将其应用到人类情绪的研究中。跟我讲讲情绪多样性的概念吧。情绪。跟我讲讲情绪多样性的概念吧。因此，情绪多样性或我们所说的情绪多样性，是我们每天体验到的情绪的丰富性和相对丰度。这确实来自于生物学和生态学的研究，表明更多样化的环境，无论是从存在多少不同种类的物种方面，还是从这些物种在环境中分布得多么均匀的方面，往往更具弹性。所以我开始研究我们可以如何捕捉这种多样性以及情绪的丰富性和平衡性的概念。事实证明，生态学中有成千上万篇论文就是这样做的。
And the formulas and models to capture biodiversity, which you can apply to emotions. You can see, you know, how many emotions or what is the intensity of the most dominant emotions in a person's life? Are people experiencing a wide range of emotions or is their experience concentrated on a couple feelings? I'm fascinated by the idea that you're not just using the metaphor of biological diversity. You're actually borrowing from the science of biological diversity here. Yeah, we borrow the tools of ecologists. There are actually many different ways to compute
以及捕捉生物多样性的公式和模型，你可以将其应用于情绪。你可以看到，你知道，一个人生活中最主要的情绪有多少种或者它们的强度是多少？人们体验到广泛的情绪，还是他们的体验集中在几种感觉上？我着迷于这样一个想法，即你不仅在使用生物多样性的隐喻，你实际上是在这里借用生物多样性的科学。是的，我们借用了生态学家的工具。实际上有很多不同的方法来计算
diversity and some ecologists would focus on richness. That is, how many different types of species can I encounter when I sample a forest for two days. And that could be, you know, the number of distinct emotions that a person experiences. But other ecologists might be more concerned about the relative balance or abundance of emotions, right? It doesn't matter if there's like 10 different species, if 95% of the individuals in the ecosystem are from one species in particular. And so you can start looking at these two facets of diversity and I think that leads to also interesting insights when it comes to our emotional life. So you and your colleagues have used these measures to study a large number of volunteers and you find that having a greater range of emotions can produce
多样性，一些生态学家会关注丰富度。也就是说，当我采样森林两天时，我会遇到多少不同类型的物种。这可能是，你知道，一个人经历的不同情绪的数量。但其他生态学家可能更关心情绪的相对平衡或丰度，对吧？如果有10个不同的物种，但生态系统中95%的个体都属于某个特定物种，这并不重要。因此，你可以开始研究多样性的这两个方面，我认为这也会带来对我们情感生活有趣的见解。所以你和你的同事已经使用这些指标来研究大量的志愿者，你发现拥有更广泛的情绪可以产生
tangible effects. What is the effect of emotional diversity or emo-diversity on physical health, Jordi? So we got access to the Belgian social security data. And it turns out that every year the Belgian government sends a survey asking people all kinds of questions about their health habits, their medical consumption and so forth. And they also included a measure of emotions. And what we found was that, you know, beyond the average level of positive or negative emotions that people experience, the richness and sort of the evenness
切实的效果。乔迪，情绪多样性对身体健康有什么影响？因此，我们获得了比利时社会安全数据。事实证明，比利时政府每年都会发送一份调查，询问人们关于他们的健康习惯、医疗消费等各种问题。他们还纳入了一项情绪测量。我们发现，你知道，除了人们经历的积极或消极情绪的平均水平之外，他们情感生活的丰富性和某种程度上的均等性
of their emotional lives also predicted their health. And in particular, we found very tangible relationships between emo-diversity and often people went to the doctor. The average consumption of drugs and prescriptions that they had that year. The number of days they spent at the hospital. So this was not self-reported health. This was data that was quantified by the insurance company in the Belgian government.
也预测了他们的健康。特别是，我们发现情绪多样性与人们去看医生的频率之间存在着非常切实的关系。他们那一年的平均药物和处方消费。他们在医院度过的天数。所以这不是自我报告的健康。这是由保险公司和比利时政府量化数据。
I understand, Jordi, that your research has examined the effects of emotional diversity on mental health. What have you found? So for mental health, we found similar effects. We find that people with more diverse emotional lives tend to report lower levels of depression. One thing that really surprised us in the results is that it's not only experiencing a broad range of positive emotions, but it was also the case for negative emotions alone.
乔迪，我了解到你的研究探讨了情绪多样性对心理健康的影响。你发现了什么？因此，对于心理健康，我们发现了类似的效果。我们发现情绪生活更多样化的人往往报告较低水平的抑郁症。结果中真正让我们感到惊讶的一件事是，不仅经历了广泛的积极情绪，而且仅对消极情绪也是如此。
So negative emotion diversity was also a predictor of mental health. In other words, imagine that you experience like three hours of negative emotions this week. Well it seems that it might be better off for you to experience one hour of sadness, one hour of anxiety, and one hour of anger than three hours of one of this emotion alone, right? Three hours of sadness or one hour of anger than three hours of one of this emotion alone, right? Three hours of sadness or three hours of anger only. Besides these effects on physical and mental health, you've also examined how the experience of emotional diversity shapes how people make decisions. Tell me about this research. That's
因此，消极情绪多样性也是心理健康的一个预测指标。换句话说，假设你这周经历了大约三个小时的消极情绪。好吧，看来你最好体验一小时的悲伤、一小时的焦虑和一小时的愤怒，而不是单独体验这其中某一种情绪长达三个小时，对吧？三小时的悲伤或一小时的愤怒，而不是单独体验这其中某一种情绪长达三个小时，对吧？仅仅三小时的悲伤或三小时的愤怒。除了对身心健康的这些影响外，你还探讨了情绪多样性的体验如何塑造人们的决策方式。跟我讲讲这项研究吧。这真是
fascinating. This is very recent work from my lab, and we find that people experience greater emotion diversity tend to make better decisions. So for example, if you recruit participants and we ask them to report a current choice that they were facing, a decision they needed to make in the next couple of days. And people wrote about all kinds of things from what elective to choose to their choice of roommate, their choice of romantic partners and so forth. And then in one condition we said, what's the main emotion that you're experiencing here? And give us three reasons why you feel that way. In the other condition, the high-emo diversity condition, you said
太迷人了。这是我实验室最近的工作，我们发现体验到更高情绪多样性的人往往会做出更好的决定。例如，如果你招募参与者，我们让他们报告他们当前面临的选择，即他们需要在接下来的几天内做出的决定。人们写下了各种各样的东西，从选择什么选修课到他们对室友的选择、他们对浪漫伴侣的选择等等。然后在一个条件下我们说，你在这里体验到的主要情绪是什么？并给我们三个你这样感觉的原因。在另一个条件下，即高情绪多样性条件下，你说了
like, what are three distinct emotions that you experienced while considering this decision? And then we let them be for two weeks and we called them back. And we say, what did you end up deciding and how satisfied are you with your decision? People we had asked to contemplate many emotions were actually more satisfied with what they ended up choosing. And it's not only personal choices, we've replicated these findings with objective measures of decision-making quality, so you can see how biased they are in terms of confirmation bias. And it turns out that when people are asked to write down
比如，你在考虑这个决定时体验到的三个不同的情绪是什么？然后我们让他们离开两周，然后我们打电话给他们。我们说，你最终决定了什么，你对你的决定有多满意？我们要求考虑多种情绪的人实际上对他们最终选择的内容更满意。这不仅是个人的选择，我们还用决策质量的客观指标复制了这些发现，所以你可以看到他们在确认偏差方面有多偏见。事实证明，当人们被要求写下来时
three distinct emotions that they feel when considering a decision, they end up being less biased. And we also find that people who have, you know, higher remote diversity tend to be more satisfied with their lives, also suggesting that they might be making better choices. I'd like to look at some of the reasons why emotional diversity might have these benefits. In nature, Jordi, in ecology, we know that diverse environments are a source of resilience. Do we find the same thing in our psychological lives? That's one intriguing possibility, right?
在考虑决定时他们感受到的三种不同的情绪，他们最终的偏见会减少。我们还发现，拥有更高情绪多样性的人往往对他们的生活更满意，这也表明他们可能会做出更好的选择。我想看看情绪多样性可能具有这些益处的一些原因。在自然界中，乔迪，在生态学中，我们知道多样化的环境是韧性的源泉。我们在心理生活中也能发现同样的情况吗？这是一个引人入胜的可能性，对吧？
It could be that having a diverse emotional life prevents one single emotion from dominating our mental life. So if you're feeling sad and angry, it might be less pleasant, but that anger might prevent you from spiraling down into inaction and depression. And I think the same analogy goes maybe for positive emotions. So we know that we're extremely prone to adapt to positive things that happen into our lives, but if our positive emotions are diverse, you go on that vacation and you experience, you know, gratitude and amusement and awe and all kinds of positive make it more resilient to the edonic adaptation of emotions. In other words, if you're having a range of different positive emotions, you're less likely
可能是拥有多样化的情感生活可以防止单一情绪主导我们的心理生活。因此，如果你感到悲伤和愤怒，这可能没那么愉快，但这种愤怒可能会阻止你陷入无所作为和抑郁的恶性循环。我认为同样的类比也适用于积极情绪。所以我们知道我们极易适应生活中发生的积极事情，但是如果我们的积极情绪是多样化的，你去度假并体验到，你知道，感激、娱乐、敬畏和各种积极因素，这会使它对情绪的享乐适应更具弹性。换句话说，如果你有一系列不同的积极情绪，你就不太可能
to get used to any one of those positive emotions. If you're having presumably a mix of positive and negative emotions, your plane is delayed and that's a mix of positive and negative emotions. You know, your plane is delayed and that's a source of frustration, but when you get to your destination, it's really awe-inspiring. The fact that you are stuck on the plane on the tarmac for three hours now makes the mountain even more beautiful because you had to pay a price to actually get there. That's exactly the idea. Interestingly, we're doing some field research right now with high end restaurants
习惯于任何一种积极情绪。如果你大概有一种积极和消极情绪的混合，你的航班延误了，这是积极和消极情绪的混合。你知道，你的航班延误了，这是一个挫折的来源，但当你到达目的地时，它真的很鼓舞人心。你在停机坪上的飞机上被困了三个小时这一事实现在让这座山更加美丽，因为你必须付出代价才能真正到达那里。这正是这个想法。有趣的是，我们现在正在与高档餐厅进行一些实地研究
in Norway. And we're experimenting with inducing emotions during the meal. So this is a crazy restaurant where they have a planetarium dome like ceiling. And so you can project movies that induce some sort of emotions while people are having dinner. Just to give you an example, you might eat chicken sewers and at the same time they're projecting a chicken slaughter factory, which is very disturbing.
在挪威。我们正在尝试在用餐期间诱导情绪。所以这是一个疯狂的餐厅，他们有一个像天文馆圆顶一样的天花板。因此，当人们在吃晚餐时，你可以播放能引起某种情绪的电影。举个例子，你可能会吃鸡肉串，同时他们正在播放一个非常令人不安的鸡肉屠宰工厂。
And what we find was that if all the sceneries and videos are pleasant, people have a great meal, but they're much less likely to sort of remember it and talk about it and want to repeat the experience, that if we inject negative emotions into the experience, and like a disgusting scene in a seven or eight course meal. I mean, in some ways, there's a connection here almost with cuisine itself, right? So imagine a dish that has only salt in it or a dish that has only pepper in it.
我们发现的是，如果所有的风景和视频都是愉快的，人们会吃一顿美餐，但他们不太可能去记住它、谈论它并希望重复这种体验，而如果我们把负面情绪注入到体验中，就像在七道或八道菜的餐点中加入一个令人作呕的场景。我的意思是，在某种程度上，这几乎与美食本身有联系，对吧？所以想象一道只有盐的菜或者一道只有胡椒的菜。
That's going to be a much more boring dish than a dish, in fact, that has a variety of different salt in it or a dish that has only pepper in it, that's going to be a much more boring dish than a dish in fact that has a variety of different tastes in it. And in some ways it makes sense that a range of different emotions actually as we're eating can actually heighten the richness of our meals. Absolutely. Variety is the spice of life, as they say. What's the connection between emotional diversity and authenticity, Jordi? Another possibility is that emo-diversity is almost like a byproduct of adaptive personality traits. So people are open to experience, they're open to feelings, they're authentic, they have some sort of self-awareness of what's going on in their lives, might be more keen
那将是一道比事实上有一系列不同的盐的菜或只有胡椒的菜要乏味得多的菜，那将是一道比事实上有一系列不同的味道的菜要乏味得多的菜。在某种程度上，在进食时一系列不同的情绪实际上可以增强我们餐点的丰富性，这是合乎情理的。绝对如此。正如他们所说，多样化是生活的调味品。情绪多样性与真实性之间的联系是什么，乔迪？另一种可能是，情绪多样性几乎是适应性人格特质的副产品。因此，人们对体验开放，他们对感觉开放，他们是真实的，他们对生活中有发生的事情有一定的自我意识，可能会更热衷
on reporting a broader range of emotions. That's interesting, but to me, that doesn't fully explain why when we get people to think about different emotions that they're experiencing in a situation, we see effects on their decision making and they're making better decisions. So another possibility, and that's my personal maybe favorite, is that emotions are messengers. Emotions really are information about what's going on in our lives and what we should do
于报告更广泛的情绪。这很有趣，但对我来说，这并不能完全解释为什么当我们让人们思考他们在某种情况下体验到的不同情绪时，我们会看到对他们决策的影响，并且他们正在做出更好的决定。所以另一种可能性，这也是我个人最喜欢的，也许是情绪是信使。情绪确实是关于我们生活中发生了什么以及我们应该做什么的信息
next. And by experiencing a broader range of emotion, we have more flexibility in choosing what to do next and we choose wiser. So to give you an example, if I'm feeling extremely proud of myself, I just achieved something at work, pride might motivate me to work even harder, to take on a new project, to achieve even more. If I'm feeling grateful, that might be the opposite, right?
接下来。通过体验更广泛的情绪，我们在选择下一步做什么时拥有更大的灵活性，并且我们选择得更明智。举个例子，如果我对我自己感到非常自豪，我刚在工作上取得了一些成就，自豪感可能会激励我更加努力地工作，承担一个新项目，取得更大的成就。如果我感到感激，那可能是相反的，对吧？
When I give credit to other people, my gratitude might motivate me to express my thanks to other people. In both cases, if I only have one emotion, I might work myself too hard and exhaust myself down the line, or I might always sort of put myself in the background, never take a chance to, you know, maybe take the lead on a project and take credit for the work that I do. But if I experience the two, my response might be more adapted and flexible, right? I might take on new challenges while acknowledging the team, if you see what I mean. I mean I love the metaphor of emotions as messengers Jordi and I'm thinking about somebody who might be a president or a prime minister and you're
当我把赞誉归功于其他人时，我的感激可能会激励我向其他人表达我的谢意。在这两种情况下，如果我只有一种情绪，我可能会让自己工作太辛苦，最终精疲力竭，或者我可能总是把自己置于背景中，从不抓住机会，你知道，也许在一个项目中带头并为我所做的工作邀功。但如果我经历这两种情绪，我的反应可能会更有适应性和灵活性，对吧？如果你明白我的意思的话，我可能会在承认团队的同时承担新的挑战。我的意思是，我喜欢将情绪比作信使，乔迪，我在想某个人可能是总统或首相，而你
sitting in your office and messengers are coming to you from different parts of your country with messages about what's happening in your country, but you're the kind of president or prime minister who doesn't want to hear negative news. And so you kill all of those messengers and you only listen to the people who are telling you how great everything is. That can make you feel good in the present, but it has a real risk because at this point now you're completely blindsided to any problems that you're having in your country and that might make your reign somewhat short-lived. That's an excellent analogy and I want to take it one step further.
坐在你的办公室里，信使从你国家的各个地方带着关于你国家发生的事情的信息来到你这里，但你是一个不想听到负面新闻的总统或首相。所以你杀了所有这些信使，你只听那些告诉你一切都多么棒的人的话。这可以让你在当下感觉良好，但它有真正的风险，因为在这个时候，你对你国家正在发生的任何问题都完全盲目了，这可能会让你的任期有些短暂。这是一个极好的类比，我想把它再推进一步。
So it's not only just like listening to the positive news and not the negative messenger, but it's also, are you always listening to the same messenger among the ones that bring you positive news, or are you listening to everyone? Jordi, you also say that another reason emotional diversity might be beneficial is that well-differentiated emotional states can give us more precise information about the world.
所以这不仅是只听积极的消息而不是消极的信使，而且还在于，在带给你积极消息的人当中，你是不是总是在听同一个信使，还是你在听每个人说话？乔迪，你也说过情绪多样性可能是有益的另一个原因，是分化良好的情绪状态可以为我们提供关于世界的更精确的信息。
What do you mean by this? Well, imagine that, you know, something bad happens. Maybe at work, a colleague made a comment and you're not feeling great about it. If you're just feeling bad, it doesn't really tell you much about how you should react, right? But if you pause and you ask yourself, okay, I'm feeling bad, but how bad like what is it? Am I irritated and my you know sad and my Envious of that colleague like what is it? No, depending on the answer and the specific feeling you have you have options to respond if it's
你这是什么意思？嗯，想象一下，你知道，发生了坏事。也许在工作上，一个同事做了一个评论，你对此感觉不太好。如果你只是感觉不好，它并不能真正告诉你关于你应该如何反应的太多信息，对吧？但如果你停下来问问自己，好吧，我感觉不好，但有多不好，到底是什么？我是被惹恼了，还是你知道我悲伤，还是我嫉妒那个同事，到底是什么？不，根据答案和你具体的感觉，你有选择去回应，如果是
Frustration you might confront the person If it's sadness, you might do something that cheers you up, you know. You have more flexibility. I mean, and it's interesting, I think, when we talk about our emotions, we often have this tendency to lump all of the positive emotions and all of the negative emotions into one bucket. You know, someone asks you how you're doing, you say, I feel great, or you say, you know, I'm not feeling great. And of course, what you lose with that is that you're actually collapsing probably a dozen different emotions into one bucket without actually looking to see what specific
沮丧，你可能会与这个人对质。如果是悲伤，你可能会做一些让你高兴起来的事情，你知道。你有更多的灵活性。我的意思是，这很有趣，我认为当我们谈论我们的情绪时，我们经常有这种倾向，把所有的积极情绪和所有的负面情绪塞进一个桶里。你知道，有人问你过得怎么样，你说，我感觉很好，或者你说，你知道，我感觉不太好。当然，你随之失去的是，你实际上可能把大约十几种不同的情绪折叠进了一个桶里，而没有真正去看看我从不同的情绪中得到了什么具体的
messages am I getting from the different emotions. Absolutely. I mean, take fear and anger. They've been studied quite a bit in judgment and decision making, they have opposite effect on or tendencies to act, right? So if you're experiencing fear, you might be more risk-averse, you are more cautious in your estimate. If you're experiencing anger, you tend to take more risk, you tend to be more confident in your judgment. So they're both unpleasant emotions, but they have completely different action tendencies. And I think by being able to sort of explore with a lot of precision what we're experiencing,
信息。绝对的。我的意思是，以恐惧和愤怒为例。它们在判断和决策中已经被研究得相当多了，它们对行动有相反的效果或倾向，对吧？因此，如果你正在经历恐惧，你可能更厌恶风险，你在估计时更谨慎。如果你正在经历愤怒，你倾向于冒更多的风险，你倾向于对自己的判断更有信心。所以它们都是令人不快的情绪，但它们有完全不同的行动倾向。我认为通过能够以极高的精度探索我们正在经历的事情，
we know have a better, we have better material to make a decision. Our emotions aren't just there to be felt. The reasons we have emotions in the first place is that they are designed to shape our behavior. When we come back, how to use emotions, both good and bad, to help us move toward what we most want in life. both good and bad, to help us move toward what we most want in life. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. When someone comes to you with a tale of woe and wants to share why they are sad, is your
我们现在知道了更好，我们有更好的材料来做出决定。我们的情绪不只是用来感受的。我们首先拥有情绪的原因是它们旨在塑造我们的行为。当我们回来时，如何利用积极和消极的情绪来帮助我们走向我们在生活中最想要的东西。积极和消极的情绪，来帮助我们走向我们在生活中最想要的东西。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。当有人带着悲惨的故事来找你，并想分享他们为什么悲伤时，你的
first impulse to hear them out or to fix the problem to make them less sad. Many of us, with the best of intentions, try to make our partners and friends feel less sad. But psychologist Jordi Quodbach says we may be making a mistake. Jordi, you say that rather than suppress or deny our negative feelings, we should use these emotions as sources of information. Now, one way to do this is to examine the different strains that our emotions come in to identify multiple distinct emotions. Back in your grad school days, I understand that a friend of yours once helped you to do this. Can you tell me that story, Jordi?
第一冲动是听他们倾诉还是解决问题以让他们不那么悲伤？我们许多人怀着最好的意图，试图让我们的伴侣和朋友不那么悲伤。但心理学家乔迪·夸德巴赫说，我们可能犯了一个错误。乔迪，你说与其压抑或否定我们的负面情绪，我们应该将这些情绪用作信息来源。现在，做到这一点的一种方法是检查我们情绪的不同种类，以识别多种不同的情绪。回到你的研究生时代，我了解你的一个朋友曾经帮你做到这一点。你能告诉我那个故事吗，乔迪？
So back in grad school, I had what I thought was the brilliant idea to use the university internet to advertise one of my studies. So I sent an email to the mailing list asking for volunteers to participate in my survey. Now, that mailing list went to everyone from the dean to the head of departments to the janitor, 5,000 workers at the university. And I published my survey, but it wasn't working. I could not get any sort of confirmation message that the email was sent. So I clicked, press again and again and again. And I did it probably like nine or 10 times before I gave up.
所以回到研究生时代，我有一个自认为绝妙的想法，那就是利用大学互联网来宣传我的其中一项研究。所以我给邮件列表发送了一封电子邮件，寻找志愿者参与我的调查。现在，那个邮件列表发给了从院长到系主任再到门房的每一个人，大学里有50,000名员工。我发布了我的调查，但它没有起作用。我无法得到任何邮件已发送的确认消息。所以我点击，一遍又一遍地按。我可能这样做了九到十次才放弃。
I went to bed and the next morning I opened my inbox and there were like 300 and something angry emails from professors, top executives in the school, you know, complaining about them and being really nasty about it and I felt terrible. So in other words all the messages actually did go out? All the messages did go out and so 5,000 people working at the universities at all level had received 10 messages of me asking them to participate in my survey. And I was this, you know, young grad student. It felt horrible. And, you know, some of these messages were nasty. I remember one top medical professor sending me 10 angry messages in a row. Oh my God. Just sort of as a payback. And so I started spending hours and hours that day replying to every single angry email,
我上床睡觉了，第二天早上我打开收件箱，里面大约有300多封来自教授、学校高管的愤怒邮件，你知道，他们抱怨这件事并且态度非常恶劣，我感觉糟透了。换句话说，所有的消息实际上都发出去了？所有的消息都发出去了，所以大学里各个级别的5,000名员工都收到了我要求他们参与调查的10条消息。而我只是这个，你知道，年轻的研究生。感觉太糟糕了。而且，你知道，其中一些消息非常恶劣。我记得一位顶尖的医学教授连续发给我10封愤怒的邮件。天哪。这算是一种报复吧。所以我那天花了好几个小时回复每一封愤怒的电子邮件，
apologizing, trying to explain that I didn't do it on purpose and I was so sorry to waste their time and so forth. And I was feeling extremely guilty. And that guilt was sort of motivating me to try to repair my mistake by apologizing over and over to all of these emails. Now, later that night, I went for dinner with a friend who's a psychiatrist. And I was telling him the story and he did the math. He's like, Jordy, you know, there's 5,000 people roughly working at the university. You got over 300 emails of hit me.
道歉，试图解释我不是故意的，我很抱歉浪费了他们的时间等等。我感到非常内疚。而这种内疚某种程度上激励着我，试图通过不断地向所有这些电子邮件道歉来弥补我的错误。现在，那天晚后，我和一个当精神科医生的朋友一起吃晚饭。我正在告诉他这个故事，他算了一下。他说，乔迪，你知道，大学里大约有5,000名员工。你收到了300多封抨击我的电子邮件。
These people emailing me, they're emailing a poor grad student to insult him because it wasted five seconds to put my messages in their trash box. It didn't make any sense. And so I think I went from guilt to experiencing mainly anger towards these professors. And that changed everything because guilt motivated me to apologize and spend hours, you know, engaging with some of these people, would reply back, still angry and so forth. But no anger, you know, was motivating me to do something else, which
这些发邮件给我的人，居然去骚扰一个可怜的研究生，发邮件来侮辱他，就因为把我的消息放进垃圾箱浪费了他们五秒钟。这根本说不通。所以我想我从内疚转变为对这些教授感到愤怒。这改变了一切，因为内疚促使我道歉，花了好几个小时，你知道的，去应付其中一些人，还会回信，依然很愤怒等等。但是没有愤怒，你知道的，是在激励我做别的事，那就是
is like, screw these people. So I wrote a short email to the rector apologizing, promising I would never use the mailing list again to recruit participants and turned off my computer for a week and life went on. There was no negative consequences. And probably if I had engaged with all these angry people one by one, the negative consequences would have lasted much longer. So this is a really powerful example from your life, Jordi, but I'm wondering what advice would you have for listeners in terms of how they can identify the different emotions they might be experiencing in any given situation or even perhaps the different emotions they might be experiencing in any given situation
就像，去他的这些人。所以我给系主任写了一封简短的邮件，表示歉意，承诺我绝不会再利用邮件列表招募参与者，然后关掉电脑一个星期，生活照常继续。没有任何负面后果。可能如果我跟所有这些愤怒的人一一交涉，负面后果会持续更久。所以这是一个来自你生活的非常有力的例子，乔迪，但我在想，对于听众来说，你有什么建议，关于他们如何在任何特定情况下去识别自己可能体验到的不同情绪，甚至也许是他们在任何特定情境下
or even perhaps the different emotions they might be justified in experiencing in any given situation. So I think we can ask ourselves two powerful questions. The first one is what flavor of emotion am I experiencing right now? I'm feeling bad, What flavor of bad? Well, I'm annoyed.
或者甚至可能是他们在任何特定情况下有正当理由体验到的不同情绪。所以我想我们可以问自己两个有力的问题。第一个问题是，我现在体验到的是什么风味的情绪？我感觉不好，什么风味的不好？嗯，我很恼火。
Okay. What flavor of annoyed? Well, I'm irritated. All right. Then the second question is, what else am I experiencing? Is this just irritation? Well, no. I'm also a little bit proud of what I did. And I guess I'm irritated I'm not being recognized for what I did.
好的。什么风味的恼火？嗯，我很生气。好吧。第二个问题是，我还体验到了什么？这仅仅是生气吗？嗯，不。我也为我所做的事感到有点骄傲。我想我也因为我的所作所为没有得到认可而感到生气。
Okay, so now we have more information to work with. Now I went from feeling bad to having two feelings, you know, pride and annoyance. And I can act on these feelings probably in a more flexible and adaptive way than if I just stuck with, you know, I'm not feeling good. You know, I once took a drawing class many years ago and the instructor told us that the most important thing in drawing was to be able to see what it is that we were actually drawing.
好吧，现在我们有了更多可以处理的信息。现在我从感觉不好变成了有两种感觉，你知道的，骄傲和恼火。我根据这些感觉采取行动，可能会比我只停留在“我感觉不好”这种状态下，采取更灵活、适应性更强的方式。你知道的，多年前我上过一次绘画课，老师告诉我们，画画最重要的是能够看到我们实际在画的是什么。
That most of us look at a tree and we see a tree. But a tree, of course, is not just a tree. You know, it's a set of physical structures. It has shape, but it also has light. It has texture. It has color. And your ability to see the tree in all of its granularity really predicts whether you can actually draw the tree.
我们大多数人看着一棵树，看到的就是一棵树。但一棵树，当然不仅仅是一棵树。你知道的，它是一套物理结构。它有形状，但它也有光线。它有质感。它有颜色。你是否能够看到这棵树的所有细节，真正决定了你是否能够真正画好这棵树。
And in many cases, the reason we don't draw as well as we could is we're not seeing the world with the granularity with which we could see the world. So part of becoming an artist actually involves getting better sight, if you will. And I think what I'm hearing you say is that part of being emotionally healthier is to actually have the same kind of sight when it comes to our
在许多情况下，我们画得不够好的原因是我们没有以可能达到的那种细节去观察世界。所以成为一名艺术家的一部分，实际上涉及获得更好的视力，如果你这么说的话。我想我听到你说的是，成为一个情感更健康的人的一部分，实际上是当我们面对
emotional lives. You know, one thing is to have a wide range of emotions, that's breath. But I think we also want some depth into our emotion. And we want to be able to be very, very granular, very precise in the way we experience things so that we can have more information on what's the best course of action. Emotion prepares us for action, right? So anger prepares you to fight the wrongdoing and, you know, to stand for your right. Fear prepares you to be cautious and take a step back. Sadness prepares you to sort of again slow down and reflect. And so if we're able to experience different emotions then we
情感生活时，拥有同样的那种视力。你知道，一方面是拥有广泛的情绪，那是广度。但我认为我们也希望对我们的情绪有一些深度。我们希望在体验事物的方式上能够非常非常细致、非常精确，这样我们就能获得更多关于最佳行动方案的信息。情绪为我们的行动做准备，对吧？所以愤怒让你准备好与不义作斗争，你知道的，捍卫你的权利。恐惧让你准备好保持谨慎并退后一步。悲伤让你准备好再次放慢脚步并进行反思。因此，如果我们能够体验不同的情绪，那么我们
also experience the different action tendencies that goes with these emotions and they might be upsetting each other, right? Anger might take us too far, sadness might take us too far. But combined, it's kind of a wisdom of the crowd if you think about information, right? Each individual emotion might be biased, but together, when we sort of average the information they bring, it's pretty accurate.
也会体验到与这些情绪相伴随的不同行动倾向，它们可能会互相干扰，对吧？愤怒可能会让我们走得太远，悲伤可能会让我们走得太远。但结合起来，如果你考虑信息的话，这有点像大众智慧，对吧？每种个体情绪可能会有偏见，但当它们结合在一起，当我们平均它们带来的信息时，它是相当准确的。
Jordy says that one way to develop our capacity for emotional granularity is to expand our vocabulary of feeling words. This might include borrowing words from other languages. One of his favorites is the phrase, mono no aware, which he picked up while in Japan. It's a term, he says, that captures the feeling we have when looking at something beautiful but fleeting, like the blooms on a cherry tree in the spring.
乔迪说，培养我们情绪颗粒度能力的一种方法是扩充我们的情感词汇库。这可能包括借用其他语言的词汇。他最喜欢的词汇之一是“物哀”（mono no aware），这是他在日本时学到的一个短语。他说，这是一个捕捉当我们看到美丽但短暂的事物时所产生的感受的词，比如春天樱花树上的花朵。
So imagine watching the cherry blossom, and it lasts only for a few days. This sort of realization that, you know, the world is constantly changing and there's beauty in the change. And that concept, actually, now that I have a word for it, makes me pay a lot more attention to my walks into the park in autumn and the leaves and so forth because now I have an emotion word for it. There's another emotion word from Dutch and I'm going to butcher the name, but Uitwind, which is this feeling of being refreshed and that your worries are being blown away by strong wind and rain.
所以想象一下看着樱花盛开，它只持续几天。这种意识到，你知道的，世界在不断变化，变化中蕴含着美的感觉。而这个概念，实际上，现在我有了这样一个词，让我更加关注我秋天在公园里散步时的落叶等等，因为现在我为它找到了一个情感词。还有一个来自荷兰语的情感词，我可能要把这个名字读砸了，叫 Uitwind，这是一种感到神清气爽、烦恼被强风和暴雨吹散的感觉。
So that's really an emotion that resonates with me. And as a matter of fact, a few weeks ago, I was on my bicycle when a thunderstorm hit and it was pouring rain and the battery died. So I was soaked wet with this super heavy bike uphill. And I was about to think that this was the worst day ever. When a little voice in my head is like, oh, this is, this is really, it's wind, you know, like the wind, the rain on my face. And that changed my experience. I went from being pissed to being like,
所以这确实是一种能引起我共鸣的情感。事实上，几个星期前，我正骑着自行车，突然遇到了一场暴风雨，下着倾盆大雨，电池没电了。所以我全身湿透，推着这辆超级重的自行车上坡。我正要认为这是有史以来最糟糕的一天。这时我脑海里有一个小声音说，哦，这是，这真的是，这是风，你知道的，就像风，雨打在我的脸上。这改变了我的体验。我从气冲冲变成
hey, I'm being completely refreshed by the storm. So I think learning new emotion concepts can really change the way we appraise situations. Your research has also found that interacting with a diverse group of people can have effects on our emotional states. Tell me about this work, Jordi. So in this study, we tracked people again with smartphones and we asked them who they were interacting with and what was their mood and what we find was that the diversity of social interactions that people had, right?
嘿，我被这场暴风雨完全刷新了。所以我想学习新的情感概念真的可以改变我们评估情境的方式。你的研究还发现，与形形色色的人交往会对我们的情绪状态产生影响。告诉我这项工作，乔迪。所以在这次研究中，我们再次用智能手机追踪人们，我们问他们正在和谁交往，他们的心情如何，我们发现人们拥有的社交互动的多样性，对吧？
So if you think about having five hours of social interaction, are you spending these five hours with only a couple people? Are you spending these hours with different categories of people? Relatives, friends, acquaintances, coworkers, and so forth. And controlling for the sheer amount of time we spend socializing, which is good for our happiness, we also found that the diversity of our social portfolio predicted higher wellbeing. And part of the reason, again, at least, you know, when we look at the statistical sort of data, is that a more diverse set of friends and social relationship might bring us
所以如果你想想有五个小时的社交互动，你是和少数几个人一起度过这五个小时吗？你是和不同类别的人一起度过这些时间吗？亲戚、朋友、熟人、同事等等。在控制了我们用于社交的纯粹时间之后——这对我们的幸福感有益，我们还发现我们的社交组合的多样性预示着更高的幸福感。部分原因，再次，至少，你知道的，当我们查看统计类数据时，更广泛的朋友和社交关系可能会带给我们
a more diverse set of emotion as well. So people who have more diverse social portfolios also report more emotion diversity in everyday life. Yeah, so in other words, you could have a conversation with a work colleague and maybe that conversation is frustrating because you're working on something difficult, but you have a conversation then with a friend, and you recall a happy time from your childhood, and going through these different social relationships in some ways is allowing you to dip into different kinds of emotions. just social interactions, other research from other labs show that the diversity of activities that we engage in every day is also directly linked to the diversity of emotion we experience. So the more different kind of things that you do in everyday life, the more likely you
更多样化的情感。因此，拥有更多样化社交组合的人在日常生活中也会报告更多的情感多样性。是的，换句话说，你可能会与一位同事交谈，也许那次交谈令人沮丧，因为你在处理一些困难的事情，但接着你与一位朋友交谈，你想起了童年的一段快乐时光，经历这些不同的社交关系在某种程度上让你能够涉足不同种类的感情。不仅仅是社交互动，来自其他实验室的其他研究表明，我们日常参与的活动的独特性也直接与我们体验到的情感的多样性相关。所以你在日常生活中做的不同种类的事情越多，你
are to experience different flavors of emotion. Some years ago, Jordy got to see first-hand the benefits of emotional diversity. He had been recruited by French television to run a live experiment where he tried to make six unhappy people happier through verified scientific techniques. Well, I was extremely stressed. I'd never been on TV, but I made it. They gave me the part. And so I moved to France for two months to shoot the show.
就越有可能体验到不同风味的情绪。几年前，乔迪亲眼见证了情绪多样性的好处。他被法国电视台招募去进行一项现场实验，试图通过经过验证的科学技术让六个不快乐的人变得更快乐。嗯，我压力极大。我从未上过电视，但我成功了。他们给了我这个角色。所以我搬到法国两个月来拍摄这个节目。
And it was a disaster. I was extremely self-conscious of my Belgian accent. The Parisian cast through made comments all the time. They made me redo the takes because I was not pronouncing the Parisian way some of the words. And I was very, very anxious. the some of the words and I was very very anxious and my coping strategy was to work harder and so I was alone in my hotel room you know every night practicing the lines that we're going to say thinking about ways to make psychological intervention visually appealing on TV you know turns out that filming people meditating for half an hour is not very exciting television. So I was very stressed about trying to make this show a success and not look foolish on television. And I worked myself harder and harder every day. It didn't really help, to be honest. I was still anxious on set, still to do retakes after retakes.
这是一场灾难。我对自己的比利时口音感到极其自我意识。巴黎的演员们一直在评头论足。他们让我重拍镜头，因为我有些词没有用巴黎方式发音。我非常非常焦虑。有些词，我非常非常焦虑，我的应对策略是更努力地工作，所以我每天晚上都独自待在酒店房间里，练习我要说台词，思考如何让电视上的心理干预在视觉上更有吸引力，你知道的，事实证明，拍摄人们冥想半小时并不是非常令人兴奋的电视节目。所以我对试图让这个节目取得成功并在电视上不显得愚蠢感到压力巨大。我每天都让自己工作得越来越努力。老实说，这并没有真正帮助。我在片场依然焦虑，仍然不得不一次又一次地重拍。
And then at some point my partner visited me. So she was in New York and she visited me in France, sort of out of the blue. And she had planned a little surprise romantic getaway in a nearby village. So I was really torn because on the one hand I wanted to work even more like I knew I wasn't great on set. On the other hand she had planned that surprise and there's no way I could tell her that I needed to work that weekend. So reluctantly I went and we had a lovely weekend, lovely sceneries, good wine, that was great. When I came back on the following
然后有一天我的伴侣来看我。她当时在纽约，她出乎意料地来法国看我。她在附近的一个村庄里策划了一个小小的浪漫惊喜度假。所以我真的很纠结，一方面我想更多地工作，因为我知道我在片场表现不够好。另一方面她策划了那个惊喜，我绝对不能告诉她我那个周末需要工作。所以我不情愿地去了，我们度过了一个美好的周末，美丽的风景，好酒，那太棒了。当我回来的接下来的
Monday on set, I was anxious because I had not prepared. I had not rehearsed the way I would typically rehearse. And I shot the scene ready to hear, you know, complaints from the director, but then the director looked at me and said, Jordi, you nailed it. This was fantastic. And the crew also thought it was great. And they're like, something has changed Jordi. And of course, you know, being Parisian French, they made dirty jokes and speculated
周一在片场，我很焦虑，因为我没有准备。我没有像平时那样排练。我拍了这场戏，准备好听到导演的抱怨，但接着导演看着我说，乔迪，你成功了。这太棒了。剧组也觉得很棒。他们说，乔迪有什么变了。当然，你知道的，作为巴黎法国人，他们开起了黄色笑话，猜测
it was due to my romantic activities over the weekend. But I think that was not really it. I think what I'd done is that I'd replenished my emotional bank account in a way. I think what I'd done is that I'd replenished my emotional bank account in a way. I'd added some happiness back and know that gave me the energy to deliver the lines better, to think more creatively about how to set up the scene and so forth. You know, Jordi, I'm thinking about this idea that I think comes from Buddhism, which is the idea that when an emotion appears in our hearts, we should almost treat it like a guest who's appearing at our house.
这是由于我周末的浪漫活动引起的。但我觉得并不是那样的。我想我所做的是在某种程度上补充了我的情感银行账户。我想我所做的是在某种程度上补充了我的情感银行账户。我把一些快乐加了回来，知道这给了我能量，把台词说得更好，更有创造力地思考如何布置场景等等。你知道的，乔迪，我想到了这个可能源自佛教的想法，也就是当一种情绪出现在我们心中时，我们几乎应该把它当作一个来到我们家做客的客人来对待。
And according to this idea, you know, when anger shows up at your house, instead of closing the door to anger and saying, I don't want you, go away, you actually open the door to your anger and invite the anger in as you would invite in an honored guest. And you would sit the guests down and you would tell the guest, you know, good to see you, thank you for visiting my home, tell me what you have in mind, what do you have to share? And in some ways that metaphor of thinking about our emotions as honored guests, I feel meshes really well with the idea that you're talking about here, which is in some ways being curious about the emotions that visit us, not just simply
根据这个想法，你知道的，当愤怒出现在你家时，不要对愤怒关上门说，我不要你，走开，而是打开愤怒的门，像邀请尊贵的客人一样邀请愤怒进来。你会让客人坐下，然后告诉客人，很高兴见到你，谢谢你参观我的家，告诉我你在想什么，你有什么要分享的？在某种程度上，把我们的情绪视为尊贵的客人的这种隐喻，我觉得与你在这里谈论的想法非常契合，也就是在某种程度上对造访我们的情绪保持好奇，而不仅仅是
being reactive to them, but being curious about them allows us to understand what the emotions are actually trying to tell us. I love that idea, Shankar. And I will add that, you know, not only you treat a guest right and you listen to them and you treat them nicely, but also a guest is not a permanent resident. You know that the guest at some point will leave. And so you listen to the guest, but at the end of the day, you choose how you want to react, rather than according the emotion, too much weight.
对它们做出反应，而是对它们保持好奇，这使我们能够理解情绪到底在试图告诉我们什么。我喜欢这个主意，尚卡尔。我要补充的是，你知道的，你不仅要善待客人、倾听他们并好好款待他们，而且客人也不是永久居民。你知道客人在某个时刻会离开。所以你倾听客人，但在一天结束时，你选择你希望如何反应，而不是赋予情绪太多的分量。
I love that so much, Jordi, because I feel like the two things we often end up doing when negative emotions appear is we either try and shut the door to the negative emotion and say, don't enter my house, or we open the door and allow the emotion in some ways to sweep us off and assume that the guest now owns the house and runs our life. And in some ways you're saying that both of those in some ways are maladaptive.
我太喜欢这个了，乔迪，因为我觉得当消极情绪出现时，我们最终做的两件事要么是试图对消极情绪关上门说，不要进我的屋子，要么是我们打开门，在某种程度上让情绪把我们卷走，假设客人现在拥有了这所房子并掌控了我们的生活。在某种程度上，你说这两种方式在某种程度上都是适应不良的。
Absolutely. And if we push the analogy a bit further, the more guests you have at the party, the less attention you're going to pay to one individual guest. You're taking care of everyone and it's great and you're having lots of interesting ideas from everyone. But the more guests you have at your party, the less likely they are to, you know, take over. Jordi Quadbach is a psychologist at Asade Business and Law School in Barcelona, Spain. Jordi, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain.
绝对是这样。如果我们把这个类比再推进一步，派对上的客人越多，你对某个特定客人的关注就越少。你在照顾每个人，这很棒，你会从每个人那里得到很多有趣的想法。但你的派对上客人越多，他们（喧宾夺主）接管的可能性就越小。乔迪·夸德巴赫是西班牙巴塞罗那萨德商学院的心理学家。乔迪，非常感谢你今天来到《隐秘大脑》节目。
Thank you, Shankar. It was my pleasure. Do you have follow-up questions for Jordi Quadbach about how we respond to our emotions? If you'd be willing to share your question with the Hidden Brain audience, please find a quiet space and record a voice memo on your phone. You can email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org.
谢谢你，尚卡尔。这是我的荣幸。你对乔迪·夸德巴赫关于我们如何应对情绪有什么后续问题吗？如果你愿意与《隐秘大脑》的听众分享你的问题，请找一个安静的地方，在手机上录下一条语音备忘录。你可以发邮件给我们，邮箱是 ideas at hiddenbrain.org。
That email address again is ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Bonds, Andrew Chadwick and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you enjoyed today's conversation, be sure to check out all the episodes in our Emotions 2.0 series. You can find them right here in this podcast feed or at our website, hiddenbrain.org. Next week on the show, we conclude our series with a look at the white-heart emotion of
再重复一遍邮箱地址是 ideas at hiddenbrain.org。《隐秘大脑》由隐秘大脑传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·帕尔、克里斯汀·黄、劳拉·奎雷尔、赖安·卡茨、奥秋姆·邦兹、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐秘大脑》的执行编辑。如果你喜欢今天的对话，请务必查看我们“情绪2.0”系列的所有单集。你可以在这个播客订阅源中直接找到它们，或者访问我们的网站 hiddenbrain.org。下周的节目中，我们将以对一种白热化情绪——
rage. I just started screaming. A full-on high-pitched, blood-curling screech of a scream. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
愤怒的审视来结束我们的系列节目。我刚开始尖叫。发出那种尖锐的、让人毛骨悚然的尖叫。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。回头见。这集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。